this is Jocko podcast number 193 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening I I often say
that I was raised in the SEAL Teams and
I was actually I mean I didn't join the
Navy until I was 18 years old
but once I was in the teams was the only
thing I knew and when I got in what
happened when you got to a team was you
got in line you got on board with the
program you got taught how to act not
just how to fire and maneuver not just
how to shoot move and communicate you
got taught how to act how to carry
yourself the attitude you're supposed to
have you got turned into a frogman now
there was no there was no explicit
course of instructions no one's given
classes on on mental toughness or
anything like that but you were you were
indoctrinated in other ways you were
taught the old ways then you heard
stories and you'd read stories about the
NCD used the naval combat demolition
units and the underwater demolition
teams you hear about they're incredibly
brave work in world war ii and you hear
about the massive casualties that they
would suffer making the beaches safe for
amphibious landings and that that
frogman heritage certainly ran deep but
at its core
the lineage that we followed that we
emulated and that we worshipped as young
seals was the Vietnam SEALs they were
the standard without question and I was
lucky because when I got to the teams
there were still some Vietnam seals
around some of them were on active duty
they were at the teams they were in
training departments or they were master
Chiefs or warrant officers or some of
them were senior officers matter of fact
the Admiral in charge of the community
when I got in was a Vietnam guy but
there weren't that many and when they
spoke we listened and when they taught
us something we took notes and they
taught us the things that we needed to
know the tactics the techniques the
immediate action drills the standard
operating procedures and they also kept
us honest because this is the 80s and
this is the 90s and there's no war going
on and there was some flare-ups around
the globe and seals got some flashes of
combat action but there was no sustained
operations and we could have slacked off
but the old breed knew they knew that it
was only a matter of time before war
would come again and they wanted us to
be ready and when the time came they
were ready and we were ready because of
them because of those Vietnam era seals
that had continued to serve and continue
to pass on the lessons and the knowledge
to the younger generations and because
of them we were ready to take the fight
to the enemy and we did like our
forefathers that's what we did
and it is an absolute honor today to
have one of the longest-serving seals
clocking in at 47 years
the last Vietnam sealed to be on active
duty and he's here with us tonight
Master Chief
Kirby her El Master Chief well I'm the
show and thanks for coming on man hello
guys how you doing I'm honored to be
here and honored to to talk to all of
your supporting people out there and let
them know what my story is and what a
great story it is and what a wonderful
life I've had as I told the vice
president the other day I said you know
I'd still be doing this job if I
wouldn't it got old so that's the only
drawback man we all get old it's the
John Wayne theory and if you know what
that is what's the John Wayne theory
none of us get out of here alive Shrek
ya know that's the that's the deal but
where do I start let me let me go do you
start let's start with where ever you
grew up where'd you grow up I grew up in
Missouri farm boy move to the big city
started building hot rods which big city
st. Louis okay that's the only one in
Missouri they think other ones are but
specimens so what year what year was
this that you were moving to st. Louis
oh yeah that's probably around 62 63 you
know and I that's where I went to high
school okay so I was in high school yeah
in high school at the time and CEO II
was a big thing in those days where you
you go to high school in the morning get
your math arithmetic English and then
you go work at noontime had a job site
all right and get a trade kind of
something they're coming back to now
because kids need trades right today so
I had a trade but I worked at County
speech shop so it fit perfect with my
Tony what County speed shop it was it
was a beach cottage yes that build drag
cars builder to track cars everything
else and I had a I had a 55 Chevy that I
had built up had run liquor from dry
counties to you to whet counties when I
was living in Arkansas it paid the bills
so that was good and so when I got back
to Missouri I started building bigger
and faster motors and I would
take the car down and and race for money
down on the river flats right well I got
caught one too many times and the judge
said young man I have some options for
you
well I just finished reading the book
frog man and I said you know what Your
Honor I think that going to the Navy
thing is gonna be a good deal so he said
here's my number if your recruiter
doesn't call me tomorrow I'm putting a
bench warrant out for you today so I
want to sign up for the Navy the next
morning was on an airplane that evening
headed for San Diego and the change in
my life right this is what kids think
it's gonna be like nowadays and it's not
like that anymore no it's not like that
matter of fact if you get in trouble
you're not getting in the Navy and you
damn sure aren't getting in the SEAL
Teams if you have any kind of record
they don't want you perhaps the other
thing that happens is guys think oh I'm
just gonna join and then I'll be going
the next day it's like no you're gonna
have six months eight months of waiting
around before you go completely
different world and you got to remember
the Vietnam War was so I was whaling you
I was 18 when that happened you know and
how close attention were you paying to
Vietnam at the time not really a lot I
was paying more attention to hot rods
and building fast cars you know and and
then when this thing came up and I had
to kind of shift gears realize that I
was in the Navy now okay since 1967 67
so Viet Nam's full I mean Vietnam on
right now it's on it's going so the I
got out here went to boot camp at NTC
here in San Diego and in those days you
had to go do a ship tour or Westpac tour
before you could come to the teams oh it
wasn't coming right out of boot camp and
going to butts right so I had to do a
westpac and you know my job when the
Westpac was a fireman because I happen
to be the shortest guy and could crawl
inside the boilers and I went wow what a
good deal was way back there Oh probably
about 130 yeah 130 I kept strong as a
bull right I could do 30 pull-ups and
not even bat an eye and I'll tell you
how that worked out for me when I was in
training so then the
so I was on the ship and the the cool
part about it is I didn't stay in the
fire room a long time because the people
that were taking care of the captain's
gig didn't know how to set the rack on a
slant six Detroit Diesel Trek I knew how
to set that so they got me out of the
fire room to come up and be the
captain's gig so engineers so that was a
good deal so you need 1 e 2 e 2 at the
time yeah yeah big man they big great
great so that's very cool I got the job
the boat was running great the first day
the job right on the and I was on the
USS Piedmont you had to run out on the
big booms that that swing out from the
ship so they tie up all the captain's
gigs and them all of the officers motor
boats and stuff like that well the first
day I just had taken my white tennis
shoes out of the washer they were still
pretty slippery I'm running out on the
boom slip do a backflip from about 30
feet in the air into the water swim over
jump on the captain's gig and stand in
where the engineers stands out the
timing and captain Davies who was the
was it also a shark captain
he starts applauding off the quarterdeck
Anika she said that was the best man so
needless to say home and I became great
friends great friends and and that
lasted for six months and and then when
I got back I did my my buds training
qualifications over in the pea I did
those over the pea I when I got back to
San Diego I was expecting to go right to
class right not the case because my
lieutenant had hidden the chit that I'd
pushed through and I fortunately I knew
the captain so captain Davies kind of
made that all right but I still ran from
32nd Street over to Budds training many
times trying to get all that started out
it was just good training but then I got
over to the training and captain Adi who
was over there goes man you just made it
just in time to start class 49 right
well all the pre-training that we have
nowadays that kind of prepare you for
all that stuff I wasn't there so like
three days
in the training my legs are like ready
to fall off and and so was everybody
else's right class 49 started how many
so what you checked in on what day like
how was how long was before you actually
classed up and I went like I started on
I like I got there on a Thursday we
started training on a Monday ok so that
that was the pre-training I got yeah
yeah that was the whole thing man so it
was very cool very cool
all of him all this stem from the fact
that you had read the book to frogmen oh
absolutely and you said that's what I
want to do yeah yeah that's the exact
water guy did you not really the lakes
or anything not really the first time I
was in the ocean was here in San Diego
and I had a couple of surfer guys that
were in the class because I was trying
to jump over the waves because the only
swim and I'd ever done his rivers and
lakes right and was ok with that but I
hadn't dealt with surf before and the
surfers in the class go no Kirby you got
a dive underneath the waves and it went
ok I got it
so underneath the waves I went you know
and it was great man
I think once I got my fins I felt like
you know I was a water baby then because
I could fly with the fins I never go to
near the ocean without my friends
anymore anyway it's so it was very cool
so we got so we got started I mean there
was 220 25 of us at starting class 49
and and my nemesis was was Oliveira and
this came out of my retirement right
Oliveira was this big hook-nosed indian
guy that ran like a hundred miles he was
strong as an ox and and ugly as an
instructor was another student total
instructor total instructor him and
mother my mother Moy was also an
instructor our class 49 was mother moist
first class right so we're all standing
out in front you know of the of the
building over on the old landfill base
and we're all lined up there
well Oliveira comes out and starts
looking up and down the line and he goes
eh you're too short to be here and I
want I'll be here when you're gone yeah
oh that hurt I ate half the mud on the
bottom of San Diego Fame
and it was wild but Oliveira and I have
we had we grew a relationship while I
was going through training so being the
shortest guy that ever went through buds
training right I I felt almost lu5 for
all the some days other days I'm 5/3 now
that I'm getting older I'm probably
gonna push 5 - pretty soon but he had
some more stories about that but so the
so Oliveira walks in the back of the of
the main office and tells Mother Moy hey
mother my I think you got a troll in
this class mother my gos tell your shit
means we'll go out there and look and
and there I was man it was that started
the whole cascade of of situations right
don't talk shit to an instructor that's
oh yeah I just want to advise people
that could go OK it could also go
terribly wrong
Oh cuz if you piss off an instructor
they will they will they can crush you
and destroy yourself that's he obviously
saw something in you that he liked right
but if you wouldn't seen that you know
they'll eat you alive well I I can only
tell you that every day of training
every day of training I was in the goon
squad so so that may have been part of
that what you're saying he didn't like
me kind of thing cuz no matter where I
was at if I was running in the middle of
the pack
everybody from me back was in the girls
got off for the days that I was there
cut off I could I'm one day we've just
said ok I'm gonna run in front of the
pack right and everybody in the class
goes ok that's great
because we'd whittled the class not a
lot so I was in the front of the pack no
shit
the whole class was in the good squad
Oliver he was great he was a hard hard
man but and I'll tell you the and it
goes back to what I was saying earlier
about polo so we do PT and I could I
could run hard and do a lot of PT and I
when it came to pull ups I could knock
out 30 pull-ups with nothing flat well
mother Moy and Oliver who used to make
me hang on the pull-up bar and then hit
me in the stomach and see how high they
can make the swing
everybody in the class will tell you
that Mike Thornton Mike Thornton was in
my class you'll tell you that you know
so some of the other some of the other
tidbits about going through training
Mike Mike Thornton because a dirty name
is built for big guys to all guys
because I'm short I got a big chest at
the top log on the dirty name I couldn't
get over sometimes I just would couldn't
do it well Mike Thornton would come up
there and throw me over their top log
and the instructors would get pissed off
and go sorry can you stop doing that
where would he stand would he do that
would he stand stand on the log instead
of the lower log and throw me over the
top log it was great that's great in the
end the days I couldn't do it that
instructors made me go through the
Weaver twice but all the rest of it no
problem with any of the rest of the
obstacles but that was part of it you
know in the personality I think my
personality kept me going because it was
it was a good thing and the instructors
even though I was pissing them off they
they enjoyed having me there because
when it came to to being you know making
sand cookies and and volcanoes and stuff
well if they got too close they became
part of the sugar cookie in the volcano
itself so it was very cool Oliver bought
me a steak after after after graduation
so that must have meant something right
and and mother Moy today one of my best
friends he you know he comes to every
event he was at the at my retirement you
know when I retired from the Navy I had
I had like five speakers that all came
up and and shared their their comments
about Kirby as he went through training
and motherboy was one of them so it was
classic 1500 people at my retirement
yeah yeah huge huge but anyway after
after we got through buds
you know then we went through mom we
went to SBI how many guys made it
through yeah in our class there were 22
so he started with 220 and you ended
with 20 yeah probably 10% but I got
rolled back into class 50 same kind of
thing that's where I rolled four oh
because there was a chief chief Rose who
was one of our instructors
good guy but he had come up with this
little thing called the little Olympics
where you had to do
the all these different exercises like
swim you had to swim 500 yards and your
clothes you had to push up set ups pull
ups and run a half mile or a mile and a
half in your clothes and you had to do
that all in a thousand seconds right so
I missed it by like 12 seconds and he
goes sorry we're gonna have to roll you
back and I went oh crap well I wasn't
the only one there were like five guys
in the class that got run far along were
you in training well we went through
second phase we had to go through second
phase dive phase again and then go into
the third phase but you know third phase
to me was you know that was like a
vacation because of land warfare because
a great um great shot I'm good on the
land because I was a hunter and you know
I was a country boy so I knew about all
that stuff and Mike Martin was in your
buds class as well
yeah class 50 it rolled back you rolled
into his class yeah yeah then he might
Thornton to Mike Martin yeah yeah oh
yeah that's good I never thought about
that before from one Mike to the other
and Mike Mike and I were swim buddies I
mean we did all the dives together
everything else he was a hoot when it
came to doing ocean dives because he'd
always get above me and I couldn't you
know when you're diving you're looking
for your swim buddy to the sides right
not above you and my could screw with me
all the time and hide up there in the
kelp and I go well I just lost my swim
buddy where the hell is he right well
that was when we were out on Point Loma
were you guys diving the Emerson rig oh
absolutely
you mean yeah the one that did that
bubbled the way everything yes yeah I
don't know worse when they heard they
call the green death yes yes that's this
is not a good rig well because of all of
the bags see the bags that they had on
it were built to keep you know the air
but because of your rubbing on things
and operating and everything else that
always get a wear pattern in them so
you're always off gassing in those bags
so you always had to charge them and if
you didn't make sure your bags were
charged that's why they called it the
green death yeah we we we we dope though
a lot a lot but but we made it we made
it through and then we all went to San
Clemente Island which was
another hoot and had a great great time
out at San Clemente Island blowing up
stuff shooting stuff I mean you know
it's a dream it's a dream it's a total
dream coming across the beach at night
you know it was it was definitely
definitely a good thing and then and and
once we graduated but our graduations in
those days were certainly not what the
graduations are today we were out behind
building 401 and they came by and gave
us our certificates and goes
congratulations you guys you know we all
felt ten-foot talk as we graduated buds
but at the same time there was no crowds
they heard no nothing it was just us so
different and you how did you not go to
a UDT team I was great at LAN warfare
and I was a great shot so they kind of
that's the way it worked in those days
if you were good swimmer
if you were a real good swimmer and you
were were kind of trended towards that
then you would go to UDT if you were
good at land warfare good at blowing up
things and and shooting then you'd go to
SEAL team and that's how I got picked to
go to SEAL team one because I was much
better on land than I was in the water
so that was the that's what brought us
over there Mike and I went there we went
through SBI together and now when you
get to SBI on now there's just one SEAL
team on the coast so obviously SEAL team
ones running the SBI which is though
yeah the training to get you shielded
making the actual the actual skills to
be a seal because in Budds you don't
learn a lot of Iraq
yeah and who's running that cadre the
Kadri yeah CAD ray I mean we had Mookie
Martin you know yeah and he was there
and we had a number of other excellent
guys that were had been to Vietnam
several times they were our instructors
the and they took us out to our famous
location as Nilan you know when there
was nothing there we lived in we had
trailers that old us streams silver
stream trailers dream trailers that's
what we lived in with no no windows it
was 120 degrees you know we get up every
morning and have our protein breakfast
which was fruit cocktail
a can because there was nobody cooking
anything and then we and then we'd go
work in the desert all day and come back
in that heat and then we'd have we'd
have dinner which was fruit cocktail and
a can and kipper snacks which was said
another good deal and then they had the
then they had the irrigation ditches up
at the in the desert where they would
irrigate all the fields well that was
our shower because we didn't have any
running water we would fill our we would
fill our canteens up to go train and in
the desert at the filling station in
town and off we'd go
that was the but we had a lot of bullets
and that's all that mattered bullets but
the heat was unbearable
I mean it's unbearable 120 degrees so I
got us ready basically for Vietnam
because when we got the Vietnam it was
kind of like shit this place is cold but
it's OSBI how long was SBI SBI was like
six weeks okay six weeks and and that
got us up to speed and then they got us
into ARPA tunes and then and so what
what year was this now this was 1969
1969 yeah and what platoon did you go
into it's SEAL team one at Foxtrot Putin
thought I was a point man at Foxtrot
tune squad one and Mikey was point man
squad two Mike Thornton or Mike Martin
Mike Martin Mike Martin you're right
Mike Martin I mean Mike thorn had
already been over with another species
in class 49 class 49
yeah because since we were kind of six
weeks behind those guys that's why we're
old but there was no we didn't have the
time lag they have today about going to
war when you finish SBI you were going
right now so I remember the day when
they go okay you guys are deploying and
we went over to North Island Air Station
did you do any kind of work up as your
platoon a couple weeks you know couples
are you finished SBI yeah and then it's
into a platoon you spend a few weeks
into the platoon and then off off your I
guess that wasn't really because there's
so many less seals there's only what on
the west coast or 180 seals okay so
everybody's kind of uniformed anyways
because you're all learning from the
Aksum cadre that's right and that's why
when when I came back from Vietnam
that's why they put me right into
training so because we had new guys that
had to be trained up and there was no
time like to get that going right so
that's what they that's what they were
doing the guys that were really good in
the in the field they would take them
and put them right in the training
department and get the guys that are
ready to go into an off they go so how
long was it so how long were you in your
platoon do you and Fox opportune for
like a couple months then you said are
you going on deployment probably nine we
were we were in there three months prior
to deployment and then we deploy we'd be
over there six months and come back and
then they break the patina part and off
it goes
was there any I mean was there any like
this anti-war stuff that would you even
think about it
we were all way too busy to even think
about that I mean we we saw it when we
got home you know because of the because
of the anti-war stuff and all that kind
of stuff and you know and we were too
hardened to even caring here right
waiting care and so that we just kind of
blew right past that we never got into
anyone I mean when we got home there was
kind of a demonstration outside of of
North Island you know about that kind of
thing we drove right by a bus so was no
no big deal so what was in your so how
old do you now right now are you like 19
20 years old yes
so you're 20 years old you're on your
first deployment to Vietnam yeah yeah
how I turned 21 over what was your what
was your thoughts flying over to Vietnam
well we had like a c-17 which was like a
World War 2 plane that we were flying in
and it seemed like we flew forever
and you know and then the cool thing
about is when you left North Island they
give you a box lunch then when you're
landed in Hawaii they gave you a box
lunch well the you know the Box lunch
was like an egg an orange you had a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich and in
a meat and cheese sandwich and some milk
so what's your bucks lunch and and off
you went man we went in high style you
know and we landed at Taunton ood
Airport we we landed there
and they hung out there for a while and
then the even before we had to fly from
constitute down to bend to e because our
the Special Operations Officer SEAL team
office was at been to e so he flew into
there I flew into there because I was
like the part of the pre-party to go to
see float and start setting up for the
new platoon and run the first ops stuff
with the with the old petunia and stuff
like that so that was we flew from there
the arrestee guys stayed in the Victoria
Hotel you know in in Saigon at the time
and we took off and flew down to been to
e
got ready to catch a bird and go on down
to C float and well you pretty much just
completely amped to go and get some oh
absolutely
we all are you mean yeah but that's a
way that's who we are right yeah we want
to get with it we wanted to get with the
program and and get there as soon as
possible we did our breaking up
you know what about older guys that were
on there whoo-hoo and your platoon had
been on like three four or five
deployments already well the chief that
we had chief Jones had been on it he'd
been on a couple of deployments my radio
manly Pitman who had been there we had
another guy a yachts who was our
security guy you know and they're all
good guys all good guys and what was
their attitude like going back babe
what's rockin electronic yeah let's rock
soledad Lee Pitman was my was was the
best he was the best radio man you could
ever want
right he was in there callin oment isset
he get over here you know but they were
all a you know I think I think probably
the biggest guy the gun-shy one was the
chief he he just had seen a lot of war
and I don't think that he really he knew
he had to be there because he was the
chief right but some of the shit that we
got into you know he just it was time
for him to go home mm-hmm right and so
we did we sent him home because when the
shit we got into man I mean one night
when we got ambushed on the damn toy and
Mike probably told you this but we were
going in and I
I was going on a sampan we had like four
sand pads on the bow of the of the
sealed light support craft and I was
asleep in the in the sampan right we hit
this canal called the damned oi
something woke me up I think it's a guy
upstairs you know ain't that the Lord
was going Kerby it's time for you to
wake up so I woke up and I go holy shit
and I jump I start to jump in the boat
and a b40 rocket blows the bow of the
boat off I roll and come up right behind
right I'm holding on to the 50 caliber
machine gun we're right in the middle of
the kill zone of an ambush everything we
learned right if you're in the kill zone
blast your way out of it so that 50
swung around and it just started
blasting and I had a couple of guys on
the floor which the chief was one of
them and they were Lincoln that 50 Cal
Hamill and that 50 Cal was going for
everything it was worth man people on
the on the banks guys were shooting
flares and every time I saw a guy that
50 caliber took him out so it was like
we were to doing damage but by then the
first boat that Mike was on Miss Mike
Martin they had called in the Seawolves
so the Seawolves were scrambling here
these guys come flying over many guns
blaring the door Gunners have got their
white BVDs on and flak jackets they
never even took time to get dressed and
they're blowing the shit out of this
place over there right so by the time we
got all that settled the the I had had
bullet holes through my clothes that had
burned my skin but no through and
through everybody that boat was we had
to scrap the boat because it had so many
bullet holes and it was unbelievable
Mike's boat the medium support had to
tow us a line then we had to make a
circle and come back out of the damn
door hell of a firefight hell of a
firefight went on for a long long time
and a and when we got back to C float
you know the the boat that I was in was
almost ready to sink right so it was it
was very well destroyed but nobody got
shot nobody got killed
I got burn marks that was the biggest
that was the biggest deal but the
that was a wild time in the and the
Coxon whose name was at Willie Willie
Williams that guy was uh he was an older
guy right and every time he'd go out
with us he needed to take a shot of
whiskey just just to keep himself off
take the job and he was like a limit
yeah he was that was one crazy night for
Willie but we all made it home safe you
know I'm ready for the next day so when
you got there what was that what was the
primary was a mission that you guys were
tasked with doing what were you guys
doing well we were you know when we got
there Admiral Zumwalt had told a bunch
of barges oh right 13 barges we called
it sea flow you can go online and look
at it it's a bunch of barges that
supported all of the riverine boats and
all of the air squadrons in South
Vietnam so it's set they anchored it
right in the middle of the Sun cool on
River with these giant anchors right so
it was probably about 100 yards you know
on each side of it on the river banks
and tell the tides you know went when
the tides changed over there because
there were a 14-foot tide change then
you'd have mud banks and stuff like that
so it worked out perfectly the problem
with it and that's where we were all
stationed the problem with it was that
the sappers would use the current and
tie explosives on a line let the
explosives float down with the current
and hook around your anchor chain and
then these explosives would come in to
the side of sea float and try to blow
you up so all of the guards that were
posted 24/7 at the thing would have to
watch out for that and shoot it out so
in a millon it-- when you're trying to
get sleep and all of a sudden this big
charge blows up you go a little cool
look well that one didn't get us and so
that was the that was life on sea float
I mean every every mess where your
birthing Wars and everything everything
everything yeah birthing showers food
everything that's where our offices were
at and all that kind of stuff so it was
uh it was an experiment to do that very
successful deployment on that thing yes
well except when I was working Phoenix
program if I was working Phoenix program
then I would go to different locations
right but they what we usually would
launch off of there and some of the
Phoenix stuff we would do or two-man
sampan ops where myself Leon Roush rest
his soul him and I would get in a sampan
and take Casey s Scout with us and we
had paddled ten clicks into bad guy
country and snatched this guy out of his
hooch and bring him back because he's uh
was a bad guy
we're high level VC high level VC where
would that Intel come from from the kid
Carson Scouts from Navy intelligence you
know from from a lot of different areas
and we would bring it all in because we
sent a lot we did a lot of our own
intelligence gathering in the southern
region down there explain the Phoenix
program for people that don't know what
it is
well the Phoenix program was designed by
the agency and probably several other
people and what it was was to root out
the bad guys in villages that were
working kind of like double agents that
were working for the South Vietnamese
government also working for the Viet
Cong so what we relied on what this
Phoenix program relied on was Intel from
the locals that this guy was a double
agent and then when we got that then we
would send teams in to snatch the guy
and bring him out and do further
interrogation on by not only us but by
other groups you know and that worked it
worked well until the bad guys started
fingering good guys
and now the intelligence was all mixed
up so you know in the beginning of it it
worked fantastic because we got a lot of
a lot of bad guys you know basically out
of the jungle but then the bad
psychological operations to be told
these guys who thought that they were
safe and thought they could get away
with it all of a sudden they disappear
in the middle of the night absolutely
absolutely and put the fear of God into
him that's right that's what the men and
the green faces did was make them
disappear and you were running two-man
operations
oh yeah getting in a getting a sampan
and you were paddling how how far would
you guys paddle I think the fathers we
ever the deepest we ever want was
probably 10 klicks from a safe zone
which into
would you care for radio where would you
carry your radio we carry regular radio
prick 2525 yeah yeah and I carried I
carried eight but you're dressed like a
Vietnamese oh absolutely black pajamas
you know what is nighttime so they can't
see that you're a white boy from this
right that's exactly exactly right
probably the hairiest op did I tell
everybody about this up because Leon and
I went on on this OP and we captured
this high-level VC and we're paddling
back so let's lives if it's a good one
let's talk about it so this is Phoenix
program operation Phoenix program
operation and you get intel on a bad guy
right they tell you okay now how
detailed was the intelligence that's
what you would get would date say okay
here's the village would you get
overhead imagery of that village no not
in those days so you just would look at
a map we would look at a map we would
talk with our K CS and a k CS were more
kind of guys that we paid on our side to
that knew the local area cuz we had
captured him but we had switched him
over to our side we were paying them we
also had a village with their family
that we supported in it so we made sure
that they weren't going to go to the
other side because her family was
visiting us right so that was the whole
thing so they would help us decide
exactly where this we're at and they
were good guys and for the most part
they were wonderful operators so you'd
be looking at you okay there's a village
at this grid coordinate or whatever
you'd look at it you'd do a map study
looking at the river sure and you think
okay when this River turns to whatever
to 80 degrees then we have to go another
200 meters right in the village will be
on the left side of the bank absolutely
and then work the tides because remember
the tides are 14 feet so you got to move
with the tides there's nothing moving
against the tide you can move at ebb how
about you then you got to move with the
flow would you try and time it so you
were going in with the tide and coming
out with the tide oh yeah that was key
yeah if you didn't do that you're kind
of screwed yes well you're very slow one
way or the other and then you're going
into a little like this is just your
stereotypical Vietnamese village elapsed
a bunch of little hooches
yeah and you would know hey third hooch
from the water on the right-hand side
it's got a whatever a freakin that's
exactly right
that's exactly right that's how we would
target it and then okay so you go up you
paddle your track and are using any
night vision at all are you trying to do
it with moon with Half Moon with
starlight did you want it completely
dark what did you Hollis ideal all the
half moon would have been ideal but then
that's all we would have but you don't
always get that so that was the whole
thing so that was a roll of the dice
sometimes and depending on what the moon
coverage was at you know untied yeah you
know what was going so you always had to
work those two especially with a two-man
team two-man team you don't have a whole
lot there I mean you got everybody on
standby what are you carrying for a
weapon
stoner man come on I didn't go anywhere
I thought Betsy she was she was with me
all the time she was a great equalizer
how many rounds would you carry thousand
and what and what like two canteens of
water and a K bar and you're good maybe
some grenades maybe one can t no water k
bar a medical kit and four grenades and
I was good that was my black pajama
outfit and so a body armor body armor
was a t-shirt with a bull's-eye painted
on and you're in black pajamas and so
you get so you paddle up and then you do
you just beach the boat yeah Coast right
in goes right in it's quiet is there any
other activity on the water at night and
if it there isn't another VC activity oh
absolutely absolutely well I'll tell you
a story about coming out of one of the
villages where there were you know that
mean they're moving the same way you're
moving they're moving with tides and
everything else if they're moving at
night are they DC yes okay yep only of
people out there that were friendly were
us and that and the philosophy goes
everything on this OP everything
everybody that's on this ops coming home
safe everything else is not right so
that's what it was
so we slid into a village one night so
we slide in
we take the people we want knock them
out filming the bottom would you two
knock him out hit him with the hammer
hit him with the whatever just standard
operating procedure carry the slapper
you know a slapper always works man slap
her on the jaw you'll knock a guy try to
suppress weapons mm I did 22s
that's all we had in those days we
didn't have a little hush puppies yeah
yeah and we did those mostly for dogs
that were meant geese that were you know
that were put out there to act as
shooting head shot on the geese that's
impressive
well yeah this but usually shot him in
the fat body with the 22 with the 22
long they go but the but the stoner one
night were coming out
we met some VC going in we were just
kind of laying out waiting for the tide
to change and we were laying in the
weeds right and a VC sampan came by and
I put my stoner up have my stoner
pointed at him following on Sat pants
and he reaches out to knock all the
weeds away and touches the cold steel
well his eyes were very big at that
moment but they weren't big for very
long
so we eliminated those boys and kept on
movin yeah it's a once you get in a
contact like that now everybody knows
you're there everybody's grant
everything gets scrambled everything
okay so now you're scrambling to see
wolf so absolutely and they come out at
night to try and help you oh yeah we had
a guy from we had a dentist rally on
here from he was a Seawolf pilot good
and he just was just awesome all awesome
talking to him they didn't care about
anything oh they were going they were
gonna know if you guys call them they
were going 100% they were only there
they were full-on and if you haven't
seen their new video you got to see it
we put out the word scramble the
Seawolves
yes scramble to see wolves you got to do
it's a great great film and talks about
those guys and you can't say enough
about those guys they're coming now to
our our Vietnam you know parties
get-togethers that we have because they
were so vibe
to our survival you know they saved our
ass way more than we can even count yeah
crazy Christine he told a story they
were they they stayed on station so long
they he goes looking around on fuel oh
well they run out of fuel they land in
the middle of a pet rice paddy yeah and
they're using ammo cans to transport
fuel from one Nolan said is they they
were all garage mechanics those guys
were unbelievable I mean I was a hotrod
mechanic so I understood the mechanism
but what they did to get those birds
airborne in the beginning was phenomenal
I mean they took pieces and parts and
pieces and parts and ditto and to see
them do that and then you know as the
war carried on people and the army
actually started copying what they were
doing they're going out how come those
guys do that and we can't do that right
so now there's many guns on way more
aircraft than they ever had before and
that was because the Seawolves
were the ones that started it and they
put their rocket pods on there
I mean hey man you know it was all good
it was all good so you you whack this VC
that touches the barrel of your weapon
and of the sonic yeah yeah you kill him
now it's on it's on because it's been
completely silent the whole night the
whole night and all of a sudden there's
a burst of five five six rounds and now
everyone's awake yeah so now you get on
the radio
yeah and you're gonna go hey we just
were in contact the VC that our RK CS is
paddling like a wild man Leon is on the
radio and I got the stoner out of the
front of the of the sampan and we're
going how far how far away are you from
we were picked up
we were probably like three four klicks
in side BC country so that's how we had
to go 4,000 yards to get off I mean
everybody knew where we were at so the
launch was good
it was hairy they say this the good
thing is they don't have night vision
that was a good thing how even that we
didn't have night vision yeah but I mean
at that point I'd take that trade
because I don't want them to have night
vision on a river it's and
it's scary oh yeah and then on the river
it's like mmm in a combat zone you feel
real naked it Oh
if the enemy possibly has night vision
even they don't have night vision well
your ending on the mirror holy that's
your whole and distinctive reaction is
is heightened right the hair on the back
your neck everything is going right
because you know they they are feeling
exactly the same thing you're feeling
like they're going holy shit man where's
this person at because they don't know
exactly where you're at all I heard was
a burst so they're coming in they're
cautious and you're moving as fast as
you can right so that was the whole
thing we knock on wood the Lord was with
us at night and we got home safe right
and so what's your what's your extract
point do you get you meet it in the main
canal the main canal making out and
there's there's a boat of some kind what
kind of boats were you guys using yeah
the MSC we had light seal support craft
which was the one that we got ambushed
then we had medium steel support craft
which were aluminum boats that had a
step on the back of them had two twin
427 Chevy motors and them with Holley
carburetors we hypothec our rivers so
and these things I mean they were fast
and they would do 50 miles an hour plus
on those rivers so if once you got a one
step get out of the way there wasn't
anything stopping and then we had Swift
boats and we had PBRs then we had the
big junks that were down at XIV load and
everything else so there was there was
more than enough coverage to pick us up
once we're on the big river
so you're paddling out do you stay close
to the edge of the river so you're in
the dark oh sure shadows sure so try and
stay in the shadow yeah don't get in
hurry when and rush something right take
your time I mean it just you take you
had a burst nobody knows what that was
but they know there's something right
there's not one burst it's hard for them
to even triangulate by sound where it
was yes is that true in the jungle too
like in the city you goose hard dude
really hard to tell where but one burst
it'd be hard to tell where it came from
same because you have the same situation
it's that sound is bouncing off of
everything so you know that's why they
have they invented the
when we were over in Bosnia you know the
Brits had the triangulation thing where
when a mortar would go off they can
triangulate right where the noise was at
yeah and we could drop stuff right on
that that was a excellent thing we
didn't have that in Vietnam mm-hm we're
kind of going I think it's over there
yeah yeah no maybe over there right and
as soon as you're I mean you scramble
out of the immediate area but you get
200 meters away and then it's like okay
let's get quiet yes be able to the edge
say look the same thing as you do as an
insertion right you move off that noisy
spot you move in you're set your weight
is anything moving is anything coming at
us no it's not okay let's move right get
going that's where the word black came
from when you go black go black I came
from guess who that was a Vietnam thing
go black nobody knows what that word
means only you all right so when you're
all the shit's going everything else is
going go black now where does everybody
nobody knows where it's all coming from
they just suspect it but they don't know
and are they brave enough to stick their
face out there to find out not really so
that was that was uh that was one of
many I mean yeah so is that the OP I cut
you off and then we kind of ran off on
another source that the one you said
this is a story I always tell it was
Phoenix program it was in a village oh
one one up many okay so that's the one
yeah where you had that guy who had that
contact well we had like range and then
I'll go to another one that was down
south when we inserted because we had
some VC we had intelligence the VC was
coming up south we had done all the
sensor planning to in the jungles to
make sure we could pick up movement in
the jungles and stuff like that and we
got movement way down deep but we had to
go in and set so alpha but dude Alvin
Foxtrot we went down to set up on a
river that we thought they were gonna be
coming across so we moved in late in the
evening so you're setting up an ambush
we're setting up an ambush on a river on
a river right this is straight up the
same thing that you guys taught us
deflating re Morse the same thing they
it's absolutely the same thing claymores
on each flank Claymore in the rear let's
watch see what happens right so I'm on
the left flank right I run my Claymore
I'll come back in I'm sitting right and
all of a sudden I hear movement right so
I'm watching the tides the tides are
going down and I see this bridge start
bubbling up from the water so they have
a hidden bridge in it so I see that the
only saving grace is were on high ground
they're on low ground I see all these
guys there's like 80 guys down there
that are trying to come across that
bridge to do a ambush on sea float on
the Sun cool on River so I let the first
guy right
I tell though get so he scrambles those
guys right so this guy comes walking
across and it's a point element what's
the range from you probably when I
initiate probably five feet so so he's
got to walk up like this of the bridge
right well I'm right here so the old
owner comes over and I go whoa and we
light them up all right you're nades
boom boom light them up and overhead Oh
V tens right and one of the pilots lives
right here in town Colbert we call him
we throw the we had tiara which was kind
of the early stages of Kim light juice
that we could throw in the water that
marked our line so we threw that in the
water marked our line and the ov-10s
come flying out of the sky and they're
coming from like 3,000 feet directly at
the ground let ins loose the zoomy
rockets going wow wow wow and they're
getting kind of close I'm going blow the
claymores and get the hell out of here
so we're blowing the claymores and we're
going
the hell out of there right and these
guys are just tearing it up across the
river and so we're taking off and all of
a sudden we hear this run so so we're
taking off well what was was our our
lieutenant had just pulled his life
jacket just enough in the frenzy who
wear the co2 car to was listed was
weeping so we're a holidays we're
hauling ass back up the canal it was
what a night that was holy shit man and
then we sent down a group of Arvin's the
next morning to check it out and they
there was like 80 dead bodies down there
so it was so on up like that what how
did you guys insert we inserted a boat
up the river we're sorry how far off are
away with you guys properly probably
click ok so pretty close yeah and you're
patrolling what are you wearing you're
wearing are you wearing blue jeans I
didn't wear blue jeans at night I did
wear blue jeans but that night I didn't
wear blue jeans
how about barefoot oh no Jim Bird is the
only one that does barefoot yeah no I
wore my boots and I'm glad I wore my
Vegas yeah that that always seemed crazy
to me but I know those guys that did it
oh man I know so I and I don't guys that
did it too but I hate when I'm moving
I'm moving way too fast to worry about
stepping on something right yeah cuz it
was that was a busy night and so for a
night like that since you're not wearing
the black pajamas you're wearing web
gear you got your stoner you're still
carrying a thousand rounds thousand
rounds offensive operation are you
bringing more grenades we would have
probably you know what smoke I mean it
since I was appointment I would I would
have carried whatever the red or the
green smoke and the radio man usually
carry the red smoke if we need to mark
something if we need to mark an LC they
would have it somebody else would have
yellow and purple you know out through
the out through the squad and then in
the squad how many sixties would you
have in the squad to to 60s and then
would the rear security be carrying a
stone or two you bet and nothing like
far superior yeah so anyway
what about would you would be so there
be two stoners in two 60s two stoners
two sixties have sometimes three stoners
and two 60s the lieutenant would carry
m16 right a OIC would probably carry and
they would probably have you know I'm 79
m79 s are have a two or three underneath
of it you know that's probably what
would would have went on and were you
guys in in seven or eight man squads we
were an eight yeah yeah eight men squads
right so it was yeah that was how long
would no guys plan for these missions
for oh that's you know I mean we had our
own Intel so I mean when we get
something we could put together an OP in
a couple hours and ready to go because
you know just as as every seal knows you
know once the you get there and you get
the routine down everybody knows what
their job is
that's what makes us what we are and so
we can put together not very very
quickly you know and you know just in in
Germany when I was working in Germany
you know and plus - that's what it meant
man 10+2 when you get the call you've
got two hours to get the airport get on
that airplane and get going and that
happened more than I want to we can
shift gears but the that was that was
the Vietnam War and then I came back and
so what just hold on the Vietnam War
how was your op tempo like like how
often were you guys working
we ran probably in that six-month period
of time well over a hundred ops so I
mean there were days when there would be
three pops at day you know other days
where there's two ops one up did you do
any of those parakeet hops flying in the
daytime like just pouncing on a village
or something
sure sure we did that and I'll tell you
a good story about that we we did one of
those when because I was appointment I
was a guy that hung out the door and
located the village right because we
didn't have GPS in those days so I was
hanging out the door and I'd find the
village where the bad guys were at not
tell the birds set down so we're flying
down this canal I mean we're doing every
maneuver following each Bend and in that
canal I'm hanging out the door and I go
that's the village right there
so he flares we jump on hit it
we're in a skirmish line we start taking
fire from the village not long are close
behind us are the sea wolves so we can
the skirmish line we start moving on
this village right and taken taking all
the bad guys down this village and we
call in the sea wolves well the sea
wolves come in probably ten feet over
our head with the many guns and chest
our break in the village right needless
to say we look like wile men running at
the village and that was because all the
hot brass coming out of the many guns
were going down the back of our necks
and we were going so I was gonna kill
anybody that was in front of me I don't
care who that's we all got back we all
got back to see float and we all of his
head like 20 burn marks on her back
where the hot brass had fallen out of
that many gun I went that's probably the
last time I'm gonna do that but it
wasn't but it wasn't but it worked out
and that worked out fantastic and that
was like the same what you're calling
parakeeto mmm absolutely yeah any kind
of ops stay behind ambushes all that
kind of stuff we did all that we
incorporated all that and our tactics
how often would you guys get contact for
the enemy on an OP so if you did a
hundred operations how often would you
guys get contacted with the enemy you
know I want to say 70 percent of the
time because we did most of our own
intelligence so we were always involved
in contact you know it wasn't there were
a few times where we walked and walked
and dry hole dry village that wasn't
wasn't where it was supposed to be but
the majority of the time we had contact
which was which kept us all kind of you
know jazzed and ready to go very pumped
that was the whole thing but I kept it
real because we were all we knew when we
go out we were gonna have contact so you
better have your shit in one bag dude
how do you guys do for taking casualties
well you know everybody in Fox opportune
except for one of our officers who
I have to laugh because Mike Martin
pointed out a booby trap to him and he
turned around to tell somebody about the
booby trap and walked into the booby
trap and it puts some bb's in his butt
so he so he was a casualty he's so we
had that we had to fly him back to see
float and get to get the holes in his
ass patched up but but other than that
everybody I think I mean we all got hit
but nobody got hit so badly that they
had to they had to be medevacked off now
our group when we were there is when we
had the biggest loss of life in in
Vietnam when the helo went down that we
lost five guys we got off of that bird
and that bird that operation was an
operation that we had just come off of
because we have we went after a Russian
adviser to the to the Vietcong we had
him in a in a village he was able to run
out of that village and run into the
forest you know that was at the end of a
rice paddy so we decided to go after
that but going after that we got met
with like 500 VC because they had a
whole company size element down there so
we kind of got it handed to us in a bit
but nobody nobody lost their lives we
were able to get back on get back break
contact get on our birds and get home
but the bird took some took some hits
right so when it landed at sea flow we
told them shut it down let's take a look
at it the army pilot said no no I all my
gauges are good it's good everything
else
why are five guys Jack Donnelly and Toby
Thomas and Sparks and Ritter and Gore
got on the bird to go up to bend to e10
in like a thousand yards out from Ben
tui the bird spun its rotors and
inverted and and the guys all of them
were skydivers so they all left the bird
you know and tracking across the sky but
what happened is they some from what I
know is they hit the hit the rice
paddies and stuck in the mud and drowned
in the in the rice baby they couldn't
get themselves loose from the from the
mud so that was a that was a crime we
all cried about that I was they were
Gargery great team guys that was a bad
bad day in our lives what they do with
that platoon just back filled it back
fill that you know and the and then we
all kept working because when we got to
see float there was one platoon Foxtrot
was there when we left there because
there was so much action we had four
platoons that they're trying to cover
down on on everything that was going on
right so it was a it was a very active
active place another good app I'll tell
you about that was a square B Square Bay
op which was a location right up from
the entrance of the Sun cool on River
Kenna was at night the VC would run
supply trains down across square Bay in
San pans and deliver it to the VC which
were down south of us that we were
always hitting so we found this out so
we decided to set up an op on on square
Bay so I we built a I built a twin 60
mount for the Boston Whaler which we had
silent running you know twenty fives on
and we took that up the square Bay and
we parked in a little cove up there and
just waited that night we had night
vision or a great big night vision glass
and we're watching these Sam patents as
they're coming across us where Bay and
there was like twenty five of them and
we said wow this is the wild wow West so
we got on the boats the boat driver was
there got on the 60s and we hit it and
we hit it because the square Bay very
shallow probably 10 foot of water mm-hmm
and we come across there blaze in them
60s and all those guys in that in that
whole sampan sticking out like dogs
balls so we just let them have it let
them have it with one Boston Whaler one
boxer sixties 26 days on it
well yeah and there's how many Sam pans
there's I think there was like 40
right so I mean we had other team guys
in the boats with the stoners and stuff
right so we had these guys devastate
them devastate them and now we got now
we got 40 San pans full of fish rice you
know guns everything that the bad guys
need down south the he we waited for
daylight which was probably about 45
minutes so we just let him set there
right waiting for any guys that kind of
pool blood that wanted to get up and
shoot again so we just said then we then
we approached once it started breaking
daylight right so the only person that
was alive was this old woman that was
chewing beach nut had like three teeth
gone so so we made her drive so she
drove all the sand pants back the sea
float it was wild I know I know there's
helos because there was helos over the
top of us somebody was taking a picture
of that but it was it was a magnificent
thing right and bringing all these
samples back to see float and then we
gave them to we distribute that at them
to the village that we had started which
was upriver we had captured so many
people at sea float that we started a
village upriver probably about probably
about a half a mile from sea floating
and we just that was our village right
so we anything we would recover anything
else from the Vietcong we would give to
the village it was a fishing village
right started with like five people by
the time we left country it was like
1500 people who are these people they
were just innocent fishermen and you
know and innocent citizens that had
gotten caught up in the law right and
they were trying to get out of the war
zone so we moved him up there great
fishing where it was at and the and you
know they would go to market you know
which was up in bunk towel and not vung
tau but then tui and and sell their fish
and all that kind of stuff so they were
just trying to make a living so we would
take everything to those guys so that
day they got all kinds of fish and
brand-new Sam pans and everything else
they loved us I love those Americans so
it was very that was very cool very very
cool the old lady we took the old lady
up there too
sit you have a new home now she just
kept going
she wonder beats none crazy crazy man
but that was one that was one crazy op
that made the history books so it was it
was good but you know we all got home
safe which was a blessing you know
except for our five guys we lost their
he lost their lives and you know and
then we had the mighty moe got got
ambushed when it went down south we lost
Mikey got hit then should have got a
Purple Heart didn't walk slen got hit in
the eye with a piece of shrapnel what
happened with that what was it well the
mighty moe was a Big Mike boat you know
had all kinds of armor on it and
everything else and what they were doing
which they shouldn't have done we're
trying to punch away through a canal
down to VC country
well the VC had grenades and had mines
and everything else on it so when the
boat would go down there it get would
catch on cables right and then snag
their props so they became in mobile so
they were setting ducks when all these
mines started going off and they got hit
from all sides by the VC so the VC
really shot the boat up again sea wolves
got us out of there came in black ponies
got us out there where to go pull the
boat out but the guys that were on the
boat you know we're inside and the
Rockets were going inside and the hot
core was bouncing all over the place so
we lost I think two guys that day and
wog son got his eye put out and then a
lot of other people got shrap metal
wounds and stuff like that' off of the
off of the mighty mole but that was not
not a good day and it it probably
shouldn't have happened but it did right
so a lot going on when you're wrong out
there pushing how'd you decide when your
last op was gonna be - you know I I
can't answer that question cuz we were
working so hard you know and everybody
goes okay we're gonna we're gonna stop
operating two weeks right before we take
off well that didn't happen
we just operated up I know I I know that
when I got home off a hop I got my gear
and put it on a helo and flew off that's
when my last day was so and I know the
rest of the guys were probably very
close to the same you know because I was
one of the last guys to take off we did
the turnover op with the new platoon
coming in you know and that's when we
moved off of we moved off of of sea
float and moved into solid anchor
because they had built the base over on
weeds
you know stabilize the situation and not
before the Seabees could come in and
build the base you know over on the
shore I always felt like it was a jinx
to say okay this is our last stop oh
yeah I never said that
no I just we just kept going and then
one day was like guess what we're gonna
go home so we can't do anymore so that's
right that last stop that we just did
that was our last on it's exactly the
same way jinx it yeah you know no and
you know because our world it's push
push push
I mean we're all jacked up to do
everything we can and you want to do
that I mean the time to sleep is on your
way home I know I came off of one of the
Africa hops that we did down in Sierra
Leone right and we'd save probably 3,000
people you know and that particular
thing and got them back safe and stuff
and when I jumped on that c-140 fun to
come home and I looked at all the guys
that were there with us I go man this
hero shit is really hard and I went to
sleep and I went see ya later whoo - I
was gone though we landed in Stuttgart
Germany yeah it was wild it was well but
Vietnam was a great and it's just what
you said earlier Vietnam was a huge
learning ground a huge proving ground
for SEAL team if we would not have said
ahead Vietnam we would not be where
we're at today it's that simple it's
that simple and and you know the guys
the personalities they came from all
walks of life all walks of life and and
we have that same thing today at Naval
Special Warfare I mean I see it in every
young man that I see it every one of
them has gone
a different personality but the fire and
their gut and the fire in their eyes is
there and they want to do the job and
they want to do it the best they
possibly can right with all the other
crap that's going on I mean you got to
give it to the men the men and we're so
fortunate to have the quality of men
both officers and enlisted that we have
in Naval Special Warfare because they're
professional they get the job done every
now and then they drop the ball but for
the most part of they get it done yeah
so so you come home from Vietnam like I
come home from Vietnam I I get on my
Harley and I sounds like a plan right
there it was it was a plan it was a plan
I well I had a chopper shop so I came
home I had a chopper shot before I left
to go to Vietnam and and I had so had
the chopper somewhere exciting I go yeah
in Imperial Beach okay all right so I
built it I built the bike I built Mike's
first bike Mike took off went back to
Ohio I said you know what I'm gonna
build the bike and I'm gonna go for
right so I built the body toured around
the United States met Americans again
which was a real eye-opener because you
know a lot of like today a lot of guys
have a lot of mental problems adjusting
from the war and stuff like that I used
to travel around the country to adjust
myself right I didn't have a lot of
money
I had a great Harley and I would I'd
stop at work get a job for a day or two
get some gas money get some food money
put it in the tank and I'd hit it again
and I I made around the country and
enjoyed the hell out are you on leave at
this point no no a lot of the Navy oh so
this is so you came home yeah what'd you
do just when you got home when I well
when I just got home home from Vietnam I
went back to the training cell I was I
was on active duty for another two years
okay after I got home were you planning
to get out when you got home we like
okay well when Vietnam ended I you know
I don't I didn't know I was there for a
you know and the whole thing was I got
out I was out for like 90 days did this
trip around the country and then came
back and got back on active duty you
know and and I said well you know it's
the only thing I know and the only thing
I love so I'll do that and then
I got off of active duty cleanly and
went into the reserves in 75 and at 75
that's when we started the seal reserve
unit and in San Diego and also on the
west east coast and so I was in the
reserve unit you know as a centered
class second class Petty Officer made
first class and the reserves and then it
was your civilian job at this point I
had a couple civilian jobs I had a I had
a barter shop that worked and did Navy
repair ships over at 32nd Street Long
Beach and then I go up the Swan Island
and do stuff up there because I repaired
boilers because it was easy mechanical
stuff machinery stuff and so I did that
had a company of probably about 15 guys
we did that for a while then I had got
another company that did it and that
grew at about 90 people you know and
then I got rid of both those I sold
those and then a friend of mine came to
me and wanted to start another company
with the it's called the take off an
estimating system the company was called
tech Sonics and and we came up with and
devised a system where if you put a set
of building plans uncited on the top of
a digitizing board we had a guy that
wrote the algorithm that would can tell
you if you touch that stylus in two
different points it would give you the
dimension of that eight-foot wall tell
you all the pieces that you needed to
build that tell you what your labor
costs would be and everything else so he
sold about 5,000 of those systems across
the world and and we sold that company
to a group of Canadian guys and that's
when I went to reserves in 1990 and they
said hey we need some volunteers to come
back for Desert Storm Desert Shield I
went I think that's me it's so so that's
what I really engaged with active duty
at that point you had spent that whole
time in the reserves at that 15 years
I'd spent in the researches one weekend
a month through we had the summer so we
had a weekend in a month yeah weekend a
month and two weeks there
and we we were very creative about that
we you know we would do cold water
training and the Colorado River and a
big raft yeah that was good and then we
do cold weather training and and mammoth
of mammoth yes yes train trying to get
down the hill as fast as you possibly
could yes it was hell but somebody had
to do it but we always got the chute and
we got the blow-up things to keep our
walls up we got the jump which is which
was better in the reserves than it was
on active duty because you always had a
sense so that was very cool so for those
15 years that's pretty much what I did
and then 1990 how you went in and I got
called back to active duty you went the
SEAL team 3 started working a training
cell with Mike Martin and K bar and a
couple other guys that were there and
were you a master chief at this point
known and was a first class okay oh yeah
oh yeah because in the old days rank
never meant anything I mean some of
those ops I was telling you about in
Vietnam we ran him as second class petty
officers you know I mean so what so the
rank was never a big deal and so not
till I got back on in 1990 did I realize
that rank was a big deal and I went
Jesus I guess I better study it's so in
the Chiefs test come around I took the
Chiefs test we were in German than not
you know and it's there wasn't anything
I didn't know about in German so fired
up how fired up was Mike Martin to have
you checking back in to seal T there oh
he's great well Mike when when Mike
originally came back he lived with me
you know he moved in the house we so
after visa Mike got out yeah and then
what did he do
good story oh yeah absolutely Mike Mike
got on that Mike got on the bike I built
him and rode back to Ohio that's where
he met Gail his wife right so Mike went
to work at the steel mills back in Ohio
working the steel mills with his with
his new Triumph motorcycle right so he'd
ride it there and he was working there
that's where he'd learned to tattoo you
know he ran into a guy back there that
was a also a biker and learned how to
tattoo from the sky
and that became his new career well the
steel mills after 13 years the sea steel
mills were gonna close down so Mike went
to a reunion in Florida and saw Steve
frisk who was one of our who Mike worked
with in Vietnam he's one of the two-man
ops right him and Steve would do the
two-man ops together and myself and Leon
would do the two-man ops together we
went down there saw Steve and and frisk
was a commander I think in the teams at
the time and Steve goes hey if you want
to come back in I'll help you so that's
how it happened right got back in
because of a something vet like a ham
vet or something like that I don't know
what it was but as a program they had
where they're trying to bring you know
vets back on that had skills and stuff
like that it might got it and fell into
that category well then he calls me you
know and I'm still in the corporate
world doing business and stuff like that
goes yeah it's me Mike Martin I go I
know a lot of Mike's so he starts going
off on me and I go all right Mike I got
it I got it
so he came out hung around I gave one of
my bedrooms and and he lived with us
till he got back on his feet and got his
family moved out here everything else
but what a wonderful deal for him right
because the steel walls were down there
was no job for him back there and he was
able to get back on active duty and come
back on active duty and everybody knows
what a stud
he was so that was just cool besides him
wonderful personality wonderful man
wonderful wonderful man great brother
great great brother so we had we had
tons of fun you know rehashing the thing
and then all the new personalities that
you know I had at Team 3 like Shirazi
you know Mike you know and they were
like on and on like the Chang or hey it
was a it would it was a welcome you know
thing for me to come back into because
being in the business world you don't
have that kind of camaraderie that you
do with the guys right so the guys are
there and that's what it's all about
anyway it's about the Brotherhood it's
about the camaraderie you have with one
another coming back and I know Mike and
I miss both of that and when we came
back together at SEAL team 3 it was just
happening so we let it go from there you
know and that and it proved to be
fantastic so I was in SEAL team 3 from
from the 90s until 95 95 I got autres
which I was a chief now over to
Stuttgart Germany to move unit 2 from
mcenany Scotland down to Stuttgart right
I get over there and I'm gone holy crap
Germany right now my wife was gone
Wow Germany because she's starting to
travel and she loves it right so we got
over there and then we got into the into
the world of moving from mcenany's
Scotland we had to go get all the stuff
from the base at Mack rohini Scotland
which is a story all its own and drive
it down to stood guard and they gave us
the worst base in Stuttgart to fix up
right that Panzer cancer concern yeah
which was Ronald's old
tanker oh yeah yeah you know and that's
all that goes a whole nother thing but
we the the they still have the cranes
omj is there to pull the engines out of
the Panzers yep they're well they're in
there they're in the base it's like part
of the building I know I know all those
all those cages that you see in there
guess who put those up I reckon a new
yeah yeah you saw who was wild but I had
the Ordnance Department training
department at the time when we were
moving then so that was that was a good
thing and then we got onto the Esat team
and the rst teams where we had to start
one second you threw your wife into this
scenario there yes yes when did that all
start oh yeah well I probably should
discuss that my wife was my biggest
supporter right so you know as as we
were going through this and going back
on active duty in the 90s she had never
been involved in the Navy at all and
right so Mikey and I are going out to
niland to train the guys at Nilan and
I'm going hey honey I'm gonna be gone
for a couple weeks
well she was a professional woman had
her own
career and stuff like that and our son
was John was old enough to kind of take
care of himself so she'd say okay we'll
just call me let me know what it is so
it wasn't that big of an affair so we
were going and then she worked for San
Diego Gas electric so when I got hottes
to Germany she retired from San Diego
Gas & Electric and this was a new
adventure for her so she was all excited
about going to Germany and everything
else and so it was great for her I mean
she absolutely loved going there did you
was your son old enough to that he went
to Germany or not no he was he turned
into a college boy okay
college boy in my house paid for it yes
uh-huh all my neighbors were calling me
in Germany called I reckon the house
there recognized I'm going Olli crap so
oh you left him here
College in your house yes yeah yeah big
mistake but you know what we lived
through it that's the whole part we
lived through it so she wasn't very
excited about it so it was it was a fun
it was a fun move because it was her
first one as we go on through the career
she's going this is not getting to be as
much fun as I thought right so she got
there and we got moved on to Kelly
barracks right well because I was a
chief I got the top floor right and the
barracks well there's four floors 90
steps every time you go up no elevators
so every time she would buy groceries
the groceries would be waiting at the
bottom of the steps forgets who to carry
up when I got home right
laundry she'd bring the laundry down I'd
take the laundry back up and it was like
oh my god so now I know why the Germans
have such strong legs because everything
up and down those things
it was crazy so that was a it was a good
move we got into a real rhythm over
there where we really just defined
general Lambert was the general there
and he loved you know Naval Special
Warfare so we justified by being on the
Esat teams and being on these rst teams
we justified our existence there and
everybody wanted us to be there because
any time we would go on an operation the
operation will work
that's where the Neil's came in to how
we started doing the Neil is in Africa
that's that's a noncombatant evacuation
opera right where there's something
going wrong in a country whether it's
civil unrest could even be disease it
could be disaster
but there's a problem and somebody's got
to get basically the Americans out of
there you know and so you know you've
seen him happen all over the world and
you did you did one where Liberia or
Sierra Leone remember that Liberia we
did one on Liberia we did one in
Brazzaville we did one in Sierra Leone
and we used I mean you used all methods
and the reason they this is a reason why
they wanted us on cuz we were the marine
piece to it so if there was any landings
that had to come I had to survey the
beaches before the guys got there had to
make sure they had access on and off of
the beach all that kind of stuff I was
secure that was my job plus going to the
embassies find out what kind of supplies
they have what kind of food what kind of
medicine and all those kind of things so
when they called us to go down and do
this you kind of took control you worked
at the at the ambassador's hesse pretty
much but the military guy could take
over at any time yeah because this is
these operations are so vast and the
responsibilities because you've got
security obviously but you've got
logistics you got medical you got look
you got food supplies I mean there's all
these things that have fuel everything
yeah I mean it's a it's a massive
undertaking to get a thousand two
thousand three thousand people rounded
up trying marshaled into an area and
then extracted from that area I mean
that and and keep them comfortable the
whole time at least all as someone
comfortable otherwise you're gonna hear
about that - yes you will I'm gonna call
my representative but that's it but
that's the whole thing that's I mean we
had to go out in town I'll break it down
just like the first one the first one we
went on was into Liberia Liberia was we
landed in Sierra Leone is early on as a
safe-haven and that was the best place
to do that because we just surveyed the
airport and stuff like that well you
know when Sierra Leone is your safe
haven you know you're going into a rough
it's not the safest neighborhood anyway
so the so we flew in the Liberia and the
and the embassy was basically under
siege so we had to shut the siege down
close the gates up take care of the bad
guys that were there and start you know
vetting people coming in to the compound
the embassy because the Ambassador
wanted to save as many people as
possible he said that's great but
they're not bringing everything they got
especially people with American
passports into coming in so we were we
probably slew ninety chalks out of there
of people with with thing and I mean
when you're flying in you're flying in
low a rocket team tried to to take us
out going in and and the door gunner
with the minigun
got pointed in the right direction and
that rocket team disappeared so that was
very cool and so we flew in we had to
chop trees down we had to move light
poles we had to do all this for this
evacuation plus we had to tell catalog
everybody coming in take care of medical
stuff coming in and everything else so
our job was was big was big and the
ambassador loved this but but it was a
big job so we were on that siege
probably for about two and a half weeks
right so the we evacuated I think close
well ninety chalks so probably probably
close to 1500 people on that on that
thing and getting them out there and
they were all people with American
passports are tied to an American
passport one or the other so we we
turned that whole thing over to the
Marines when the Marg got there that's
their job and everything everything was
pretty well done we had to go back in
the end of the country fly in we'd run
security we'd pick up people and bring
them back way to recover the
ambassador's Egyptian daughter the
egyptian basser's daughter that got
taken away by bad guys so we had to go
convince them that they didn't need to
keep her so we helped them with that
decision and then we and then we got her
back so he was quite grateful and
everything else and then then and then
the news media started showing up and
they
did God but but in Liberia they have a
accountable community so we used to call
them the street sweepers because in
their in the day when the battles were
raging and stuff like that all the dead
people would be removed at night because
the cannibals would come in and go would
be roadkill to be here that was classic
and that was that's a first I've ever
seen anything like that but it was
something I think every human being
should see and realize that it's out
there but it was wild so we were able to
successfully closed that down and move
on a lot of first came out of that that
was the first time that a p3 had a
camera mounted in it and was flying
overhead and we could get the images
from the city so that was very very cool
that was a 96 so and you know how that's
grown today with all the drones and
everything else today so yeah it was it
was it was quite an operation for a SEAL
team to be there and then you state so
you stayed in Germany and you did the
other thing you mentioned I mean in
order to prepare sort of logistically
and just for planning purposes you guys
would travel around and go into
countries and say okay if we have to do
this in this country here's some
contacts or some people here's some
places here some recons
check these things out and then also at
this time Bosnia was going on it hadn't
kicked off yet it was still kind of kind
of bubbling up you know in the 90s it
was still going we would fly around we
did probably like 11 different embassies
where we put together packages on that
and knew exactly what needed to be done
if for some reason the the Americans and
those particular countries had to be
evacuated so that's something that's a
standard type of operation they just got
us involved in it because we did a good
job with it and we had a team of army
guys Air Force guys and everything else
you know and then I left them and then I
left the Germany and probably 98 and I'm
trying to think I probably had my first
we were in Bosnia because we were going
to bond steal all the time and I
probably did I don't know like four
months over there before I took off and
headed back but once I came back then I
was the I went the group one and it was
the weapons officer there and that's
when the we put the mark 46 and the mark
48 into into a contracting play and got
and got those two weapons oh yeah those
are weapons as we call them they're fire
breathers yeah they are fire breathers
so we got that done and as soon as I got
that off and running and they started
the manufacturing those then I got sent
to Spain and that's when the I took over
the training department in Spain at unit
10 and were you know is that that was
2000 2000 2003 I went over there and we
that's when we started running Bosnia we
did a couple of African gigs then but uh
Kosovo was there Kosovo was still in
Germany too because we were running at
then and that was you let me back up a
little bit but the Kosovo war as well as
Bosnia they were doing filthy Wars they
yeah the the guys that were there they
were just the sirs fucking you know
there were horrible people horrible
horrible people I don't know what
possessed them to be the way that they
are but they were horrible people they
had no qualms about shooting innocence
none at all and we had no qualms about
shooting people with guns so it was good
the you always heard the story about the
the building where the where the 130
blew the corner the building out because
we couldn't find a sniper that was in it
okay I was there when that happened and
I also was there when we we went that we
relisted in the paper on the papers
building steps there was like 10 of us
and we were flipping off to the snipers
when we're doing our reenlistment it was
great it was great and so because we had
our counters
purrs up all we wanted to see was a
barrel please let me see him barrel and
so that was a that is actually when
sniper alley just lost all its support
after we blew that that building down
killin trying to kill that one guy there
wasn't any other snipers that really
we're on sniper alley after that so it
kind of it kind of lost its its weight
because they knew that we weren't going
to hesitate to take the buildings down
if we couldn't get the guys so they
would ask us in in Ramadi you know for
good counter counter sniper technology
and and we'd say you guys have the
counter sniper technology it's called an
m1 Abrams tank that's right that's the
best counter snipers that I've seen oh
you want to shoot a snap from that
building or at least in one of those
buildings over there cool watch this
that's right all Vipers they yeah they
do the trick
it's called or furloughed and there's a
reason for it right that is so cool so
cool but that was a good thing and we
would fly back and forth to Bosnia all
the time and then Kosovo was exactly the
same thing we'd be in the woods with
chasing those guys down in the woods and
it was um you know and that was our
business and we did a good job of it
everybody loved having us there call the
United Nations people so you were in
Spain when September 11th happened I was
I was in Spain when September 11th
happened and I had just come back from
the range walked into the training
department and was watching this on on
the TV and I'm go what movie is that it
was no movie that really really sent us
home and we had to move back on base
after September low and then move back
on base and everybody started started
going how are we gonna prep for where
are we going we had a couple people come
by and talk to us that we were going to
be doing different things and we did
those different things right but none of
us I don't think any of us at that time
left to go to Iraq I think it was more
of a supportive kind of thing that we
had had 10 because I was still doing
Africa gigs going down to Africa
time I think most of the Iraqi you know
Afghanistan kind of thing at the time
was still happening from East and West
Coast that's what they broke it off and
Admiral listen came by and told us that
it's gonna be a slow crawl we're not
gonna get for the long term we're gonna
take our time we got a plan we're gonna
make sure we don't burn out our guys
alright so that was that was good
information good information then I left
he was thinking twenty years at that
time I think that he's a smart enough
guy where he was going yes I think so
yeah yeah he's very smart guy a little
bit Matt Moulson
very great guy every all the senior
officers especially the officer detailer
who I called yeah and said hey get me to
a SEAL team please right now he was like
this thing's gonna last a long long time
yeah you know and yeah he's right so
then where did you go when he got done
with Spain then I came back to cuz that
was like 2003
I came back to trade it
that's when Ronnie Cooper jobber all the
boys we put together trade at one John
it and I was the ops chief for trade at
one so Mike turcotte was if you know
Mike he was that he was the boss in the
op shop so we started putting together
that which was fascinating and I did
that from the inception of trade debt to
like 2005 mm-hmm and then I got a call
from a good buddy of mine
Doug McNutt I don't know with you know
more not but he was a detailer and he
goes hey cuz George Young had gotten hit
over when he was over in Iraq and he
needed a place to kind of settle because
he was getting retired I said will you
take my shot my spot here and I'll find
someplace else to go and so that's when
Doug McNutt I thought I was gonna stay
on the West Coast right he goes I got a
hard to feel billing I go hey where's it
at man he goes Hawaii I go Hawaii hard
to feel billet in Hawaii he goes yeah I
need a ops chief over in Hawaii
I said well you know hoggle not knowing
I have to go to SDV school Oh to go to
this billet right so now I'm a senior
citizen almost and and Doug's gone yeah
you gotta go to s do you a master chief
yet I made master chief at STV school
okay so the interestingly George was my
3rd platoon chief right and then when I
took over trade that was when he was the
master Eva trainer oh ok ok so charge
jungle yeah ok ok yeah so that's
probably his what he did have when he
went on the hunt took my job and then he
became cuz I I think Ron Cooper was the
master chief of trade and he probably
relieved or unclear probably probably
care so anyway off to 2005 all of the
SDS ski school and Panama City
how old are you I was like 56 yes
oh yeah Rosie they don't know what an s
DV is echo yes sir it's seal delivery
vehicle it's a miniature submarine but
it's not a submarine that keeps you dry
it's called a wet submarine so it's got
a motor on it and it's it's enclosed but
water comes in and out of it so you wear
a scuba rig inside of this thing and
because otherwise you know you'd have to
worry about pressurizing this thing it'd
have to be honest hole you have to get
in and out of it and so that all that
would make it too complicated so they
just take a basically a shell put a
motor in it and then you get inside the
shell and you drive this small
underwater submarine is that that like
real claustrophobic one oh yeah oh yeah
if you're yeah it's very close yeah my
friend Terry because eventually if
you're a big guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's uh it's it takes a lot of skill to
drive them and then when you have a
driver you want to keep that driver
that's real good at it I was not real
good at driving the boat because I
needed my glasses
that's the 57 year old right so so
anyway how long is that school the
school is three months at least it's in
Florida oh yeah but but still you're
doing what a tower dives I like that all
the time all the time taking the boat
apart putting the boat back together
doing it I mean you're just you're doing
what you have to do
I'm just you guys know they had your
Motorhead oh yeah absolutely right I
could take the boats apart and put them
back together driving them was the you
know another thing right state keeping
them keeping them level and all that
kind of stuff
hey watch it he can't read the numbers
on the deaf Jimmy where's my glasses
that's why I always let somebody else
drive
yeah I would right in the back go ahead
but it was but it was interesting it was
an interesting time it's something I
kind of enjoyed I wish I was better at
it but but I wasn't but I still want the
SDV team in Hawaii so I went to the team
in Hawaii became the the combat systems
officer over there because Jim Morel at
the time was retiring and so I took over
his job and that is where we started
working and doing a whole lot of very
very cool things that they're doing
today and so it was a it was a fun gig I
mean it was a fun tour over there and
then when I left that I actually went to
work on our dry submarine that was over
there and it kind of burned up so I kind
of lost my job over there which really
pissed me off because I was really
getting good at paddle boarding and so
the so so I had to come back to to work
on and that's where I took the program
over in and eight and that's kind of
where I wrapped up my career was running
that program and running the palms and
the funding lines and everything else
they keep the new SD v's because now we
have a new one and keeping that and
keeping the boys trained and getting
them the gear that they need and and
it's evolved a lot since I had that had
that particular job so it's so it's been
very very interesting it's been a very
interesting career
i means karla so 1967 you joined the
Navy and now it's 2014
yeah the end of 2014 it was when you
finally retire yeah after 47 years oh
yeah
wild that's why and end just for to note
- who - Oliver do all of your clients I
was I was retired for six months and
then they suck me back in so I still
work over there yes every day I go in to
do things and now I'm working analyst
stuff that's for Naval Special Warfare
and it's very exciting I mean I think
and and Jacque will tell you the same
thing I mean once you work for the boys
and you're working for the boys and for
their health and their benefit you want
to keep doing that because they're out
there on the frontlines they and they
require people just like us to keep
pushing and keep doing the best we can
do because we're we're speaking for them
they've got more than enough to do when
you're out there in the war zone yeah
yeah that's when I was I was the
Admirals aide for 13 months and one of
the things that my boss would say in
these big meetings he'd say what does
that what does that do for our seal
platoons right and and that's the always
the reminder for all the guys it was at
war comics war comes really elevated
they're looking at things you know I
remember I go to a meeting they be
talking about what kind of boat engine
are we gonna have in 2028 yes right yeah
and and I'd be thinking myself how does
this matter and that's what he would say
he'd say how does this affect the seal
platoon how is this gonna because you
know what the SEAL Teams are gonna be
here in 2020 you know they're gonna need
a boat engine I tried so if we don't
plan for it don't figure out what the
best one is right now smart guys looking
at it that have operational experience
and that care yes then they'll end up
with a piece of shit but if you could do
it right that's how we got the the mark
48 the mark 46 right it's exactly
someone like you were saying okay this
is what we need yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
very true and if you don't have people
doing that and and pushing the future
envelope then you'll always be behind
the Parker all of our peer to peer
competitors are doing exactly that and
and some of them are doing a better job
than we're doing at it so you we have
that we have to push harder
that's that's our job and so there's
your retirement there's like 1,500
people show up free retirement
right there was more but they couldn't
get in it was at the at the Loews Hotel
yeah there was how many people are
piling in from everywhere by me and I
didn't know I knew that many people but
evidently I do it so it was wild it was
well you had five people speak oh yeah
oh yeah and they were all great I mean
they were all people that had a very
important part of my career as I went
through Naval Special Warfare you know I
mean the guys that were be 5 's with me
that were now two-star Admirals they
spoke right my I mean I think I'm one of
the only guys that's had an instructor
from their training class come and speak
at their retirement you know I had was
that a mother boy mother boy I mean the
best CEO I had John McTeer he spoke at
it you know it was it was fantastic you
know so it was it was very cool
it was very very cool retirement
couldn't have asked for it to be any
better
47 years you you wrap up with that
career yes so I know that's what that
was with waivers ok yeah no kidding a
lot of waivers it's not a waiver it's a
lot of waivers and and then you you
still are working for Naval Special
Warfare but at some point you realized
that there was another mission that you
wanted to get out you wanted to attack
absolutely how did you how did you get
involved with with your next mission
that you got involved with I will um
yeah let me go and we going to that I
had a whole team guy it seems like it
always happens with an old team guy Jeff
Bromstad who was who was a sky god jefra
Jeff came to me when I right after a
retired and says hey I need your help
with this particular project that I'm
taken on and I went well what's the
project and he told me it was child
trafficking and I said well
you know I mean I've dealt with that all
over the world and we've saved thousands
and thousands of kids all over the world
because of you know assholes that that
want to abuse them and use them and I
said you know we've done that he said
but but this is American kids on
American soil that kind of piqued my
interest he had a one of the PhDs at USD
had written a white paper Amy
Carver carpenter she had written a white
paper I read the white paper and I just
went wow I had no idea that 3,000
children a year in Southern California
or being either kidnapped are put into
human trafficking in one form or another
and I said you know I have to get
involved in this some way so I met
Joseph Travers who is the is the
co-founder of saved in America saved in
America is a nonprofit organization we
don't charge the parents any money at
all to go locate their children the
children half are the parents have to
come to us they give us the power of
attorney of the child and then the child
becomes ours to locate to find locate
and identify which they do
many of them have we've recovered over
200 kids so far we will take that power
of attorney we will find the child will
locate the child identify the child and
then we work with local law enforcement
and have local law enforcement come in
and recover the children give the
children to us so we can take the
children to medical care get any DEA
evidence off of them and then we will
take them into a counseling type thing
or a safe haven so that they can come
down off the drugs the majority of them
have heroin in them they have some type
of drugs that keep them you know in a
very lethargic state so that these pimps
and predators can do whatever they want
with them very very sad state and a
heinous crime
when you're dealing with these
situations where are these children
coming from how does it happen
they they come from many different areas
the Southern California is one we've
they come from all over the country they
come from poorer families they come from
rich families there's not any
demographics on exactly how they get
there that we've been to determine yet
so we're only into it a little bit over
200 kids so far we've been working in
Southern California that's where our
main location is that we get a lot of
support philanthropic support from the
community philanthropic support from the
government so it's the local government
mean man that's the that's kind of where
we've been focused at now we've gone all
the way to Florida to recover kids we've
gone to Utah to recover kids we've gone
to Phoenix Arizona to recover kids and
so that's what we're doing now is we're
expanding saved in America from San
Diego we're over in Las Vegas at the end
of the month they had recovering kids we
could probably got four kids over there
that we've got information and intel on
that we will go seek and find call in
local law enforcement and have them
recover the children just as I mentioned
local law enforcement loves us because
we're a huge asset to them and helping
them find you know these kids because
they they don't have the time they're so
overworked so over barren by you know
runaway kids or kids that gets you know
into trafficking they don't have them
they don't have the resources to do as
much as they would like to do so it's
very frustrating to law enforcement so
when law enforcement hears about us they
are totally in tune to say hey come in
and help us all of us are private
investigators we're all insured and
license we all are CCW carriers we have
a whole network of private investigators
throughout the United States that we can
call on that nimi mac people so if we
know that a child's been taken to
another state
we will call a P I in that particular
state he will volunteer his time to go
see if he can locate that child at the
particular address or where we kind of
direct him if he finds the child then we
will fly a team from San Diego here to
go set up do the surveillance do the
watching and everything that's required
to identify that child to call in local
law enforcement that's how we've been
working to date to recover these over
200 kids now this is a heinous crime
it's a crime that I have to ask
everybody in your audience I have to ask
every grandparent every parent that's
out there to please be on the watch and
be able to identify what's happening
with these child trafficking things
these these pimps these perverts are
taking these kids they have to take them
in public every now and then just to
keep them they keep them locked up most
of the time in houses and if you see
them out on the street don't be afraid
to go seek law enforcement and ask law
enforcement that something is not right
with this particular situation because
you may be saving that child's life and
that's what we want to do that's why
we're here this all our whole
organization is about the children
that's why we are are bound not to
charge the parents for doing this people
have charged parents in the past
thousands of dollars and never found
their child for them and and how
heart-wrenching is that to be a parent
you've already lost your child and now
you're paying thousands of dollars to
some unscrupulous person and they're not
locating your child will locate your
child usually the day it takes three to
four days to locate a child no matter
where they're at in the United States
we've got I've got great computer people
I've got great people that work behind
the scenes to assist and help us even in
Mexico sometimes but we hardly ever go
outside the United States because we
work so well with law enforcement and
supporting them so this is the word I
want to get out we need your help we
need your support please go to our
website which is saved in america.org
and the whole story is there it's all
about the teams we have we're made up of
retired Special Operations guys and
retired police officers some FBI guys
some old agency guys that I've worked
with in the past and I have a whole slew
of IT guys that support us with chasing
the internet because that's where it all
starts from so that that's where I was
gonna ask you when you see what are some
warning signs for parents to look out
for grandparents to look out for
obviously the internet has got to be a
huge one right now Oh totally totally
the Internet is the is the is the media
that gets them started right and a lot
of them we call it the Don Juan guys so
you have an older guy that is pursuing a
younger girl
promising error all these kind of things
that's one thing you got to watch out
for when you're if your daughter or your
son shows up with expensive purses or
different gifts and things like that
where are they getting it they're
getting it from these pimps because
these guys are trying to lure them in to
what a good life that they can show them
if that as long as they can possess them
and the Don Juan's will keep them for
two or three months you know as as a
girlfriend or something like that then
one day they will sell her and she'll be
gone then if she's gone they will sell
her on the weekends only the weekends
because they'll bring them home so you
can feed them all week long and then on
the weekends you won't see them because
the pimp will have them out selling
these girls and I have to remind you
that you know a one person that gives
that these pimps do that is worth and
they sell them throughout that weekend
in a years particularly to $200,000 a
year so that's just an idea it's better
than any drug that pimp or that drug
dealer could push because they use them
they bring them back they let them go
back to either a community home during
the week because they don't have to feed
them they don't have to keep them
are your house and and then on the
weekends they just call them up and off
they go it's you know and yet the kids
are 14 years old so you know you kind of
say what does a 14 year old know a 14
year old doesn't know a whole lot right
and they don't listen to their parents
as well as they should so it's kind of
up to the parents to be able to be ready
for the warning signs be ready to do
something and if you have any questions
at all go to our website saved in
America org and ask the question and we
can get you steered to a counselor get
you steered to something that's going on
in the cities like I say if we're in if
one in the cities that were involved in
we have counselors we have people that
you could talk to in those cities man
you said 3,000 in Southern California
yes
shocking that's that's why I got
involved that's what I so imagine if
that's what you have in Southern
California imagine what you have
nationwide that is it's it's a crime and
it's a heinous crime that nobody wants
to talk about you hear you I mean
there's talking about child trafficking
they're talking about the immigration
problem and everything else but nobody's
talking about the child trafficking
inside the United States of American
kids right and it's done by all kinds of
unscrupulous people I mean the first
ring we busted here in San Diego was run
by Russians on Pacific Coast Highway and
we I I was blown away when I went there
so these guys are they got multiple
girls underage girls and they've somehow
gotten them off wherever they pulled
them out of their houses if they've
lured them in somehow yes they've gotten
them on drugs yes so they've got them
you know in a flaccid state of mind
where they're not thinking straight and
then they're just they're just selling
them yep they're a tool and you let me
go back a little bit but in every middle
school that we have here in San Diego
which is going to be shocking to many of
the people that are listening is that
they are recruiters the gangs have
recruiters inside the middle schools
that are trying to recruit these girls
far the don juan's so that the drug
cartels and the gangs have these as
income sources so if you go the only I
mean the schools have been real slow to
recognize that this is happening and
they are still real slow to get programs
in place to teach these kids about these
recruiters that are in the middle
schools our middle schools it's 14 years
old 13 14 year old that these recruiters
are trying to recruit these girls and
boys into this gang style life their
style of life so that they can sell them
on the weekends bring them home the mom
and let them be school girls during the
week and then traffic them on the
weekends so that is that's something
that's going on today so everybody has
to be aware of that and that's why I
asked parents and grandparents to please
keep your eyes open and be aware of
these kind of things because there is
that evil out there and it is happening
every day in our world and these kids
these days like what you're talking
about is exactly what the I don't know
what the trend I guess called the trend
of you know with social media oh I'm
gonna be rich I'm gonna be mature I'm
gonna have a cool car oh there's drugs
cool I'm gonna be I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be mature girl even though I'm only 14
years old and so they they see that and
they get offered that and that's you
know I could imagine that's how a girl
gets lured into these horrible
situations it's exactly exactly right I
want to be older than I am and I want
more stuff my family can't provide this
for me but my my honey over here can
provide it for me he gets me new dresses
new purses all that kind of stuff those
are the kind of things and those are
kind of the red flags that every parent
needs to be aware of
man all right so saved in America dot
org is the website you got your team on
there bunch old team guys too
bunch of guys I know oh yeah awesome and
and all guys that now have their private
p.i license so you guys are actually out
doing the recon work if needed
oh absolutely whether we're doing all
the where the rubber meets the road
we're there we and that's that's how we
find these kids I mean you know that the
police department if they had the
resources to do it I know they would've
known it but they don't have the
resources and that's why that's why
we're holding a fundraiser in November
on November 7th at the estonia hotel in
La Joya please go to our website
everything is on there if you can afford
to come to the event it's going to be
fantastic we have how many seats you got
we probably have about 500 ok so what
was the date on that November the 7th
it'll be at 6 p.m. our website has all
the information on it and you can buy
tickets off our website if you got any
questions about it please just go to the
website send us a question we'll answer
that it's for carpet people they can buy
tables of 10 for all of the other people
that they have are all their employees
they could donate they can do there's so
many things that they can do to help
sponsors and help support us awesome
awesome well I'll tell you what we've
been going almost 2 hours right now I
think this may be a good time to wrap up
I'll tell you right now I'm gonna listen
to this and I'm gonna have about a
thousand more questions for you ok
that's good because I was just kidding
you know when we start talking the stuff
about Vietnam and I you know the fact
that you did 100 missions you probably
debriefed three of them four of them may
be here briefly I'm gonna start thinking
about those and I'm gonna start I'm
gonna come up with all kinds of new
questions and it'd be awesome if you
could come back on because I guarantee
everybody that's less than us is gonna
want to hear more and there's a you know
we along
time ago a friend of mine put together a
book I got like 20 guys from Vietnam to
alright a story called the the book was
called the men behind the Trident by
Dennis Cummings and there's like 20
different stories of you know the people
is the first contact action that they
had in Vietnam one of my stories is in
there but it's a it's a great read and
it's out on Amazon yeah so if you guys
get a chance go spin through that that's
a interesting I actually have that book
okay I was looking at it today what I'll
do is we'll we'll do it next time you
come on we'll go through your story
we'll talk about some more stories and
and that way I seldom give out books
that I'm gonna cover on the podcast
prior to covering them I don't think and
it sometimes people get mad they go
please tell us what books you're gonna
cover and I and I don't do it because I
don't even know what book summer colors
there's so many books that I I'll be I'm
reading five six books at a time and
I'll go okay this one I like this part
now and I'll cover that books I covered
a lot of books on the podcast sure sure
but yeah so now everyone has a heads up
it's it's men behind the Trident men
behind the Cummings yeah coming and
we'll cover that next time you come on
all right yeah that would be awesome you
got anything else and then add just I
want to before we jump off I want to
thank you all of you for your support to
saved in America we definitely need it
and make yourselves more aware of the
human trafficking that's going on in the
United States of America of heute of us
children they're not foreign kids
they're us kids yeah well once again
Master Chief Kirby
sir thanks for coming on thanks for what
you did for the country thanks for what
you did the Navy thanks for what you did
for the teams as I already said it was
your generation of seals that built the
foundation of the tactics of the
operational excellence and of the
standard of will and perseverance that's
never going to be forgotten it's what
gave me my life what gave me my life is
you
so thanks for doing that thanks for
coming on and it's an honor to be part
of a brotherhood that you're a member of
yeah and thanks for having me and we
love the Brotherhood long live the
Brotherhood indeed sir all right and
Master Chief
Kirby RL has left the building real
quick
he didn't mention this for social media
for saved in America is at saved in
America on Twitter at saved in America
on the Instagram and at saved in America
on Facebook so there you go check that
out follow that support that situation
and you know we started off I started
off talking about learning how to act
learning how to get better mm-hmm Ecco
are you looking to get better yes are
you trying to learn how to act better
trying to yeah I even worked out today I
feel like that
they feel good about that I hope you did
I did any other things that we can do to
get better yes we in our lives
oh yeah big time we can immersion camp
coming up I know sold out but the point
is you do Jiu Jitsu that's what you do
highly recommend well we were yeah just
the other day when we were waiting
before we recorded and we're sitting
there just is going on your boys there
oh yes jujitsu other friends doing
jujitsu and I'm sitting standing there
looking at it listening to you of course
and just watching people - yeah even
watching did people do jujitsu when you
understand you Jitsu is thank though
filling my heart is filling it to the
brim and I'm like talking to you and
then I even said I'll say just is so
good man I'm just watching people you
know beginners whatever high level guys
whatever it's so good
nonetheless when you do it it's even
better than watching it you'll know
that's the people who do it you know
mm-hmm they'll tell you when you do it
you're gonna need a geek of course and
what gear you're gonna get none oh then
the best key
les you want the worst key I don't know
but if you want the best one you get the
origin key get the best key from origin
mancom made in America from the dirt to
the shirt yes from the seed to the key
so we got we got a bunch of awesome
craftsmen up in Maine craftsmen up in
Maine making these keys they're also
making keys they're making rash guards
for nogi I meant to say they're making
shirts t-shirts sweatshirts they're also
making jeans right now jeans is there I
mean jeans are as American as apple pie
apple pie right blue jeans
so get yourself some blue jeans you want
American jeans you know right are there
even any Amin there has to be I don't
Vera honey though there are some and you
know what they do they make these
hipster American Dreamz jeans and they
sell them for two hundred and eighty
dollars yeah that's what they do okay so
you don't want those jeans yeah unless
you do I don't know but no you don't
these are not that yeah so origin mancom
get yourself some some clothing of all
kinds including clothing for training
including clothing for working and for
cruising yeah okay of course also you
want to keep your body intact as well
while training or while just cruising
whatever but recovering mm-hmm how about
that
yes you do yes joint warfare yes the
just go read the reviews on drug warfare
and then get some yeah because I can sit
here and tell you that I take general
warfare 3 in the morning 3 at night you
take you take 3 in the morning for your
night 3 I what I was doing that when I
when I had like when you were injured
now you backed off I'm back on the yeah
I just do three ok read the reviews see
what other people say because there's
people that are like oh my mom had bad
Arthur or whatever arthritis problems
yeah and they go on during warfare which
has active proven
things in it curcumin right tumeric to
tumeric
yeah all those things so yeah joint
warfare get the krill oil that's
dishonorable right yeah that's the combo
notice that's that that's the dual
hitter get that dual hitter
oh yeah big to the N here and I'm not
recommending to do this but for sake of
this kind of experiment for lack of a
better term if you're already on joint
warfarin crew try go off it see what
happens I don't recommend them yeah yeah
don't really do it I mean that's just
it's more of a dare than you mean but
better go off it I've done it outsmart
of complacency whatever okay when you do
legs when you squat guess what you're
gonna need additional protein the steak
ain't gonna cut it so when you squat
okay when you do clean you ever do heavy
cleans and like the next day your whole
posterior chain is like sore yeah it
needs it's you know what it's saying to
you it's going
Mulk does more so listen to your body
you know people say that listen to your
body your body saying your body's saying
so get yourself some of those monk get
yourself you know what I do it when I do
when I do legs when I get done I don't
normally do this cuz it's pretty early
in the morning I'm using not hungry
anymore when I do legs a lot of times
I'll get done I'll have a little handful
of nuts you know we're talking seven
o'clock in the morning a little handful
of mixed nuts which people got a kick
out of the way I say that and then I'll
do a little one scoop hitter okay and
this is this right this is like an hour
yeah yeah maybe like two hours after yes
for me that's kind of so you don't
believe in the anabolic window you know
that is yeah I know what it is I
wouldn't say I'm not a believer but it's
just not something that I even I'm
hungry I listen to my body my body wants
more well here's the thing though I I
have a thought I thought it was to me
and my my name is proven the anabolic
window right when you're done working
out it probably is into recovery mode
then I read like all this so for those
not true your hormones do this and that
and growth hormone and all this like
good stuff as far as you go it's so
check myself the things that I've been
saying okay let it like I you say how I
eat steak all the time right
a steak steak steak people and then
people all of a sudden lesson or that's
an actual thing now the carnivore diet
oh I think it's a real thing now yeah
that same thing with me I'd be a guy I
don't need breakfast I don't like to eat
until you know ten eleven o'clock all of
a sudden it's called something it's
called intermittent fasting right this
is just stuff I just kind of lived lived
that way right so now the sudden same
thing with people saying oh your your
your discipline depletes throughout the
day wrong it's actually wrong now it's
proven wrong I was right well so anyways
what I'm saying is listen to your body
you the people say this listen your body
I'm saying say that - well I'm saying it
right now listen your body you know what
your body says your body saying MalK
yeah wife my wife mixed up a strawberry
milk with the you have one of those nice
blenders just like the power blenders
that has like a like a 40 horsepower
engine in it yes my wife mixed up a milk
in there and she I come home and she's
that guy makes those things and she was
talking like almost in a sensual voice
right can I go OK and she goes she said
something she never said she goes it was
next level but she never says that and
then she goes she goes it's the best
thing I've ever tasted in my life that's
what she said it's the best thing I've
ever tasted in my life this is a protein
shake right that's that's something
right nothing that's not yeah so yeah
and nobody we all wore your kid milk cuz
sometimes your body you your kids you
know what their body their brain their
brain is saying give me sugar yes right
their brains like give me a give me a
okay
yes right to answer that call answer
that call instead of giving you the
poison give them something that answers
the call but makes them up stronger and
faster smarter better yeah give him some
warrior kid milk although I would not
recommend that you tell your kids to
listen to their body because the kids
would be like hey my body's telling me I
want some fucking candy well if my kids
only say that yeah they're you listened
you you feed them the right thing so
Moke
yeah cuz kids listening to their taste
buds they don't listen to their
that's what I'm saying yes you're right
and your kids tastebuds call out for
that that little sweetness hit oh yeah
yeah I'll give them what works
boom slides right slides right easy my
good so there you go
right on and and don't forget about
white tea yeah Jocko white tea tastes
good
did you notice when sean Parnell was on
the podcast he's like this has so much
caffeine in him and I was like no
actually it doesn't
there's only 60 grams yeah what you're
feeling is the antioxidant kicker drink
that's the same and here's the thing
I've drank four of them too Oh before
and the caffeine sneaks up on you cuz
you keep your just it's like a steady
dose of caffeine you're like oh yeah so
and he's you know even when you're in
conversation and talking about stuff or
whatever so uh yeah he got hit with a
double triple whammy situation jack also
chuck was a store it's called jhaqo
store and this is where we we
collectively mm-hmm we can get rash
guards there oh yeah let's say get up
you when you do ring workouts using your
rings you need to you kind of need to
wear a rash guard yeah cuz you're afraid
you'll get like what is it
ropeburn yeah basic wrap burn chafing
letter arms yeah I got that I don't do
mine's not as intense as yours the
workout but I'll you know you do like
dips and in some pushup situations or
whatever you know the various things and
I felt the chafing my work wasn't long
enough on the Rings it wasn't long
enough to actually get cheese good
chafing indication yeah so you get rash
guards you can also get t-shirts the
t-shirts that I wear JP Danelle sent me
a picture he's cleaning out his closet
mmm getting rid of shirts and I was like
that's why all my shirts are the same
you know it's almost sure to the same
yeah if you like the shirts that I wear
or you like the shirts that echo worse
you can just get the shirts there in
Jocko store.com
you know just lean equals freedom
represent def core core reference I was
representing def cord the other day and
I had a little bit of sort of uh of a
little connect right because you kind of
stepping off it oh yeah and JP
speaking JP he posts a picture of
one of the troopers representing
big-time in the wild at the UFC oh yeah
that's right there was a guy at the UFC
I saw it too I tried to take a picture
didn't get there quick enough and my
little daughter who was watching the UFC
with me check she was like oh you didn't
get a picture I go someone's gonna post
it wash you know and someone posted even
before JP and my little brother text me
before JP texted me with it
text me is this a if someone was at the
UFC wearing you guys sure yeah he said
someone said that UFC wearing the shirt
that you designed echo drums no I didn't
say that
but unless we did indicate so the point
there is yeah when you see when you see
another person in the wild representing
heart on the UFC Oh on the USC or
otherwise true well you will you'll feel
that connect and chocolaty I feel it two
men in a boat everybody's yeah yeah
connected so that's that also you can
also get a trucker hat or floral exit or
you can get a beanie winter is coming
yeah hoodies heavy medium light have you
in light medium I think they're heavy
they're heavy they're normal hoodies is
what I'm saying
and light yeah a lot of cool sir I got a
new design coming out didn't even tell
you boom oh that's a big surprise but
it's you know real aim no chance there's
a 50-50 chance
well there's no seriously 50% of time
when you show me something like dang
that's dope 50% of time I got my I don't
like that at all we're gonna see about
that one and I predict it you like it
but whichever you know it's it's it's a
little bit yeah it's out big time right
on anyway yeah Jocko store.com there it
is boom also subscribe to the podcast if
you haven't already Google Play iTunes
stitcher you know where we get your
podcast and don't forget about the
warrior kid podcast we've got that as
well if you're if you got kids or if
you're an adult that just wants to get
after it more yeah go to war your kid
podcasts and you can also support a
warrior kid by going to Irish Oaks ranch
dot-com and getting some getting some
choco soap made by Eden from goat milk
on his farm
in America hmm stay cleaner stinking
big-time also why are you staying clean
if you want to watch some YouTube videos
don't watch the drunk girl fail videos
mmm we have a YouTube channel
we have excerpts on there from the
podcast Lobby watch those excerpts
because you know every once in a while
they'll miss they you know or this you
know - our podcasts about you know
something maybe they didn't have the
time of whatever
maybe it's HAP it's it's happened before
I'm saying that but don't catch the
excerpts so they can really get many
other lessons no you need to make btf
Tony compilation there's three minutes
long of him just saying awesome stuff
please yeah well I mean I'm saying just
take the top highlights micelle might be
more than three minutes it might be it
might be an eighty eight minute video
but unless the point is yes we do have a
YouTube channel and let it cool if you
wanna smell Kirby her L looks like yeah
then you can you can watch the whole pot
this whole podcast will be on YouTube
you can see what he looks like she has
expressions we also psychological
warfare which is a little sonic boost
for your brain that will make you think
the right thoughts that you know you're
supposed to be thinking it's called
psychological warfare and it will get
you over the edge of weakness and into
the realm of strength yes that's a good
explanation a little bit esoteric a
little bit but this nonetheless yeah
focus on canvas comma if you want a
visual representation of the path that
you can stare at every day when you wake
up in the morning how long on your wall
my brother Dakota Meyer is making art no
he's making graphic representations of
the path that you can get flipside
campus.com
yes so get some of that also on it on it
calm karana calm / Jocko this is where
you can get without care various other
things some some good electrolyte
magnesia and all the little minerals or
whatever but that's it to me that's like
a go to first
every performance I don't know it's good
for a lot of stuff but it's that's a
daily one as well anyway but the
kettlebells that I get hundred percent
on it 100 percent artistic ones go there
there's a lot of cool stuff on there as
well I got it got a bunch of books right
now I have a new book it's available for
pre-order if you want to let my
publisher know that they should print a
lot of these books then go and pre-order
leadership strategy and tactics Field
Manual not to mention you know you know
you don't want to get the second edition
you know it's how many chances do you
two get get to get a first edition you
get one shot don't blow it don't blow it
as soon as as soon as humanly possible
I'm gonna have them make a slight change
to the cover 2nd edition I'm gonna make
it different
oh just exist out just just so I can
tell PID positive identification from a
distance oh that's cool I see you've got
the book I'll sign it for you but I
realize where you were at when the
window when the chips were on the table
you weren't there
you're in the font-weight order that
first a dish leadership strategy and
taxes Field Manual where the warrior Kid
3 that just came out where there's a
will it is live so bust them and then of
course we have where the warrior Kid 1
and 2 and you know me bad reviews I've
gotten on those books I'm in zero
yeah it's man I think well you did get a
bad review from someone who didn't not
only didn't read it but didn't even know
what it was about
oh yeah yeah one guy called that one guy
called and said it looked like a bunch
of toxic masculinity for children or
something crazy like that I could just
reposted that about 10 million people
ordered the book as soon as I saw that
guy whatever that idiots name was well
you know in his defense I mean he did
speak too soon he that's all that was
his mistake he spoke too soon like
without looking into it you see him
saying like that and actually you know
what I did III of course just said hey
if you want also and you once you can
actually read it
yeah make your judgment see that what
what really happened then there's a lot
of people jumped on and said hey I'm a
woman my my daughter loves this book and
then someone else said hey this book
teaches people how to be respectful
this person teaching everyone and he
finally relinquished his he recanted
yeah I apologized I had to but his fans
like his own fans were like hey bro I
love your stuff you're wrong on the he
hands you gotta make into it just came
off the top that's what's funny even my
comical sort of overreaction of that guy
being an idiot I didn't do that of
course cuz I'm you know not gonna do
that
but that if I were to react it that way
he you know people would've said hey
jock who you know you're being too
aggressive he's you know what I mean
like I would've been the bad guy so it
something to say man I'll send you a
copy if you want it yeah and then you
can read it but then everyone else
wasn't me that convinces everyone else
yes it was the the the the it was the
troopers from the Commonwealth it was
troopers come and Adam hard kind yeah
you mean well not even hard they were
all that everyone just everyone I mean
there was a couple people degree of
hardness a lot of people were just like
hey you should you should actually check
it out because it's it would help you
yeah actually is a human being be better
so he essentially got that corrected via
people who actually read the books and I
will give him a little bit of credit he
reeked he recanted and said okay go
ahead I'm wrong I shouldn't have jumped
to conclusion technical so technically
is that a bad review technically no cuz
they didn't read the book good you can't
review something in experience that is
true so there's that there's there's
Mikey and the Dragons this should be
with every child the book should be with
every child Mikey in the Dragons get
this book for every kid that you know
get it for the library get it the Field
Manual discipline comes freedom Field
Manual get that book for anyone that you
know that you actually care about as a
human so that you can keep them on the
path and then of course there's extreme
ownership there's the dichotomy of
leadership the first books that I wrote
with my brother LAIV babban about
leadership and how you can take
leadership that we used on the
battlefield and apply it to your life we
got national on front which is my
leadership consultancy where we come
into organizations and solve or whatever
the problems that they have through the
one thing that matters and that's
leadership go to echelon front
for details on that EF online that is
since leadership training is not an
inoculation you need repetitive training
to get the skills down so we made F
online EF online.com interactive
training in leadership through the
interwebs we also have the muster
Chicago's done Denver sold out sorry
Sydney Australia's next December 4th and
5th so if you want to come to that
register now so you not emailing Jamie
and saying hey we didn't get to put our
things in in time is there any more
seats because there's not sold out means
we sold it out we're not like well you
know will will will sell it out but we
have a hundred more seats no it's
literally sold out so if you want to go
then go to extreme ownership calm and
register and then of course we have EF
overwatch where we are taking leaders
from Special Operations and combat
aviation and putting them into the
civilian sector so go to EF overwatch
calm if you're a company that needs
leadership which you are or if you're a
spec ops guy combat aviation guy that is
looking to move on to their next mission
in the civilian sector go to UFO for
watch calm and if you feel like you need
more than the 500 hours that we have
spent talking on the podcast then you
can find us on the interwebs on Twitter
on Instagram and on do foz Bach echo is
at echo Charles and I am at Jocko will
again like I said if you want to help
out saved in America you can follow them
they are on the same platforms at saved
in America and thanks once again to
Master Chief curb URL for his service
and the team's and it's literally like I
told him it's given me everything that I
am right now that
these old team guys did for me and also
obviously thanks to Kirby for what him
and his team is doing right now it's
saved in america.org they are out there
rescuing children and I don't know if
there is a more noble cause than that so
thank you master chief
Kirby Darrell the rest of our military
out there that also gives us everything
that we have thank you for doing what
you do so that we can freely do what we
do and to our police and to law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and dispatchers and
correctional officers and Border Patrol
and Secret Service and to every other
first responder thanks for what you do
as well for being on call each and every
day to protect us and to everyone else
out there when I think about someone
like Master Chief who has given so much
but you know what just keeps on giving
then I ask myself what what else can I
give to the world ask yourself that same
question what else can you give to the
world whose life can you make better how
much more can you give let's find out
get up move forward and get after it and
until next time this is Echo and Jocko
out